the jurgen experience so i
was doing definitely ketamine by the way
whitney's been date raping herself guys
she's been putting herself into k holes
and then getting right into that
and masturbate the ketamine is
like prescribed though it's prescribed
yeah yeah yeah it's
like a nasal spray you have it here it's
in my purse somewhere yeah
what's so funny about it is it's a nasal
spray but when i was going to raves and
doing it
we also nasally injected i mean they're
literally just
this is a pretty trace amount it's not a
lot and i only do it like a couple times
a week
a couple times a week but it's really
good let's do a bunch of ketamine and
stab ourselves like this
that's got his cooties on it it went
through his arm i don't even think we
cleaned it
good did it really go through his arm oh
it i pushed it through
and then he made you stop for a second
yeah we i hit a nerve the first time
then i had to back out and do it again i
didn't want to do it
did the frog live yeah yeah frog's fine
he shut the frog out he
threw it up in my hand do you know that
there's a book called eat that frog
that's like about getting your work done
in the morning it's just funny literally
ate the frog oh like eat it just like
get it over like get the worst part done
mm-hmm amy and i have swallowed way
weird things happen
honestly not even a sharp ice pick this
is did it make a sound at all
no it just was like puncturing a stake
and it wasn't you picked the spot
well he kind of pointed me towards his
arm like what area is a better place to
go through but it was bleeding i mean
do you think it would taste like elk i
don't think so i think people taste like
pigs
that's what they say cannibals call
people long pigs
that's literally a nickname did you
notice that
uh blaine whenever he would have you do
something he would first like doubt
himself it's almost like a
power suggestion thing where he'd be
like no no it might be fake test it out
it might be fake
remember the frog it might not be a real
frog right this might be weighted
so you can see it right there that's
where i'm going through his arm
whose hand is that that's his that's his
hand that's his hand he's like pushing
on the skin that is the darkest hand
i've ever seen in my life wait
he gets tanned he's got a lot of money
is there something
is there something it's psychological
you're very poor or you're very rich if
you're done he looks
your face joe is there something
psychological about him doing that like
touch it maybe it's fake
make sure it's not fake um yeah i'm sure
it does that with cards and
i'm sure i don't know anything about
magic but i would imagine anything you
could
do to overload the brain like if you are
distracted yeah if you're sparring with
someone or fighting
one of the things you're doing is you're
trying to overload their brain so you're
moving you do things you faint
you fake like you're going to punch then
you kick them there's but what you're
doing is you're [ __ ] with their heads
giving them too many things to think
about he's kind of doing that too yeah
like check the cards out
and then he says things and he kind of
doubts himself and asks you if you're
sure there's so many techniques involved
but he is a master amazing him doing
that [ __ ]
he had so he did a card trick with one
guy holding one of his wrists and
another guy holding another risk like he
couldn't
do anything his sleeves were rolled up
and he did a card trick for us
so cool someone i know you're not
supposed to say how magic happens but i
don't i don't think that this
counts as like but uh there was this guy
that i knew that
they're afraid you're gonna get in
trouble with the magic castle she's like
i'll never go to the magic castle again
i'm afraid jimmy is gonna be so [ __ ]
mad at me
i don't want magicians coming for me but
sometimes they carve holes into their
hands
uh like flaps of skin and that's where
they put the coins underneath like they
actually
yeah they carve like little divots in
their hands and that's how they hold the
coins
how the [ __ ] can you carve you dive it
in your skin and then you let it heal
yeah it's like scar tissue and that's
how they're able to hold the coins
what crazy [ __ ] i don't mind really yeah
is there really no way to find out how
magicians do their tricks well you have
to become a magician you have to yeah
they let you in you got to get in the
club it's amazing blaine was telling me
that he has a friend that's a card guy
that
will literally be playing with his cards
13 hours every day every time he's on
the phone with him he hears
you guys yes that's what i was saying to
him
like the way you move your hands it's
it's similar to martial arts because
when someone's really good at a martial
arts move
they have it just the pathway is just
greased and slicked and they're
they're neurons and when they do it just
it just goes and that was kind of him
with his hands
i was watching him move the cards around
i was like whoa like someone who plays
guitar really good
there's something about it or piano yeah
it's fascinating
have you seen kyle's kyle dunnigan's
joke about where he's like i'm not good
at magic but i'm
good magician hands and he like
[Applause]